قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريش سوناك ان
بريطانيا تريد هدنه انسانيه فوريه ومستمره
في غزه تسمح بالافراج عن المزيد من
الرهائن وخلال استجوابه من قبل لجنه
برلمانيه اكد سوناك ان بلاده تعمل مع قطر
لاستئناف اطلاق سراح
هؤلاء نعمل ليلا ونهارا لضمان اطلاق صراح
الرهائن بشكل امن وهذا يتضمن الكثير من
المحادثات مع العديد من الاطراف من الواضح
ان الهدنه الانسانيه قد جرى كسرها لان
حماس توقفت عن اطلاق سراح الرهائن بما في
ذلك النساء على وجه التحديد ولا اعتقد ان
ذلك كان صائبا عندما تحدثت اخر مره مع
امير قطر اثنيت على جهود قطر ونحن في حوار
معهم على وجه الخصوص حول محاوله استئناف
عمليه اطلاق سراح الرهائن وخاصه الرهائن
البريطانيين